[Música]
cuando era estudiante universitario
estaba muy contento porque ya no iba a
tener clases ni de física química y
mucho menos de matemáticas
mira muy bien tenía bastantes amigos y
lo mejor de todo es que estaba
disfrutando mi vida al máximo
un día uno de mis amigos me invita a
jugar básquetbol
seguimos haciendo
de esta casa donde orgullosamente soy
catedrático la uap
[Aplausos]
[Música]
terminamos el partido
mi amigo me fue a dejar a mi casa y le
dije que no que no era necesario él
insistió y mi hijo no es ninguna
molestia nos apoyamos y te voy a viajar
a tu casa
tomando la autopista y vamos rápido y de
repente
tomamos una curva
no llevaba cinturón fue mi error me
agarre como gato pensaba que íbamos a
romper la valla protectora y en ese
instante al menos por un minuto
perdí el conocimiento
terminamos como la imagen que está a mis
espaldas el coche literalmente boca
arriba con las llantas
con mi pie rápidamente rompió el cristal
y salí arrastrándome
mi amigo estaba colgando el si llevaba
el cinturón de seguridad
le pedí ayuda
le quita el seguro y callo
en ese instante llegó la policía la cruz
roja y estaba muy asustado porque mis
papás se iban a enojar
que por cierto están acá y les dedico
esta charla terex
sería una segunda oportunidad quería
saber cuál es el motivo cuál era la
razón por la que estaba el día de hoy
acá y la he encontrado
compartir de qué se trata la quinta
revolución industrial
voy a empezar con una línea del tiempo
la primera revolución industrial
nació en el siglo 18 en inglaterra con
la máquina de vapor
si todos acuerdan sus clases de historia
de ahí
empieza toda el área de la
industrialización
repito siglo 18
cien años más tarde que ocurre segunda
revolución industrial
la electricidad el vapor esto ocurre en
el siglo 19
y 100 años más tarde amigos llegamos a
la tercera revolución industrial siglo
los primeros celulares
las televisiones
chabelo incluso la llega a la cuarta ya
la quinta estoy seguro
como podemos ver entre la primera
segunda y tercera revolución industrial
pasan 100 años
eso se trata de cosas objetos
la cuarta revolución industrial nace en
europa concretamente siglo 21 y el
tiempo se acorta
de qué trata la cuarta revolución
industrial principalmente tres
componentes el físico biológico y
digital
y el tiempo la velocidad con la que está
ocurriendo se está cortando en esta
ocasión no fueron 100 años fueron 50
en esta cuarta revolución algo que
caracteriza es que estamos rompiendo
paradigmas porque en el 2019
no podemos seguir utilizando fórmulas
del siglo 20
no porque no esté mal sino simplemente
porque están desactualizadas y los retos
que estamos enfrentando este siglo 21
son muy diferentes a los que enfrentamos
el siglo pasado
esta cuarta revolución industrial de qué
se trata
una vez materialización de las cosas es
decir se está digitalizando
pongo como por ejemplo
el sistema bancario el dinero estamos
siendo testigos en este siglo que el
papel moneda poco a poco está
desvaneciéndose y muchos de nosotros
tenemos una aplicación del banco de
nuestra preferencia en nuestro celular o
móvil que más caracteriza la
inteligencia artificial drones
nanotecnología impresión 4d
de qué se trata esto
que uno puede imprimir y esto es real
está ocurriendo en japón un hígado un
páncreas una córnea de esa manera a
puedes el día a día de la población
porque a cortas la lista de espera de
todos los pacientes y mejorar la salud
de muchísimos habitantes en el planeta
en este contexto
en 2015 estaba leyendo el periódico y
descubro una convocatoria que era global
shoppers una iniciativa del foro
económico mundial y eso está muy alto
nunca voy a llegar
y ahí al estar representando
orgullosamente al agua ya puebla
[Aplausos]
[Música]
conocimos a líderes juveniles
presidentes ministros mandatarios que me
enseñaron a ver cosas que de inicio no
podía verlas aplicando fórmulas del
siglo 20
en la imagen que estamos visualizando
estamos siendo testigos que la
tecnología está avanzando a una
velocidad nunca antes vista
y la adaptabilidad del ser humano está
siendo rebasada
en esta cuarta revolución industrial si
algo caracteriza es que nos está
cambiando como personas como seres
humanos
pongo el ejemplo de suiza japón donde
allá es real que ya se puedan implantar
células madre no un páncreas de este
hígado
con algunos de ustedes saben tokio el
próximo año 2020 va a ser sede de las
olimpiadas y el tema de la cuarta
revolución amigos no es el futuro es el
presente es un tema que nos está tocando
a ustedes ya todos
puede compartir en la siguiente imagen
en 2000
se crearon las metas de desarrollo del
milenio
fueron 8 simplemente
no lo logramos al menos no todas y eso
es preocupante porque hay un camino hay
un gap line que nos indica cómo salvar
al planeta ya la humanidad si esto no
fuese suficiente en estas metas globales
que abarcan ahora los más de 7 mil
millones de habitantes
quince años después cambiamos la fórmula
y seguramente muchos han visto esta
imagen los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible
y les tengo malas noticias chicos el día
de hoy
si con ocho metas internacionales no
fuimos capaz de alcanzarlas
en el tiempo de 15 años que va a ocurrir
con 17 en el mismo período
seremos capaces de lograrlo o nos vamos
a quedar en el camino
estamos en una situación histórica
y nuestros hijos nietos nos van a juzgar
y va a decir mi padre mi madre mis
abuelos tuvieron esta oportunidad y
ustedes están siendo el día de hoy
siendo partícipes de la historia un
pueblo
cuando va a iniciar la quinta revolución
industrial una pregunta que mucho está
llamando la atención
empieza el debate porque me apoyo con
argumentos de las matemáticas si
nosotros sumamos el número que está
detrás de mí
cuanto nos da 5
5 curiosamente como el mes
en el que estamos viviendo el día de hoy
que curiosamente es mi cumpleaños
[Aplausos]
esta quinta revolución industrial
para romper y está rompiendo chicos
paradigmas y teorías que antes teníamos
muy arraigadas como por ejemplo que si
tú venías de américa latina e ibas a un
país desarrollado ibas a buscar trabajo
eras un migrante y cuando ellos venían
de un país desarrollado
américa latina es el gurú el experto
pero esto ya no necesariamente es así
estamos en 2019 y recuerden no podemos
seguir utilizando fórmulas que
aprendimos en el siglo 20 hoy en el
siglo 21
y viene una imagen que va a causar
polémica esta 5ª revolución industrial
con los exponenciales
pones inteligencia artificial todo que
tiene que ver con digitalización
el dna
además la nanotecnología
la realidad virtual y reitero esto no es
el futuro también es el presente
acá viene mucha de la respuesta que
ustedes me gustaría compartirles en que
especializarse donde está el futuro del
trabajo y sobre todo también el futuro
de nuestro país
en que me voy a especializar donde voy a
trabajar como me está impactando el tema
de la cuarta y quinta revolución
industrial mucha de esta respuesta está
en esta imagen con los exponenciales
antes les platico el pez grande se come
al pequeño pero ese siglo 20 eso es
historia hoy siglo 21
el té rápido se lleva lento
qué sucedió con un ser humano
tiene
un páncreas un hígado
insertado
qué término le pondríamos a este ente un
sabor
un androide
no hay como tal una respuesta hasta el
día de hoy que quiero presentarles la
siguiente exclusiva
si toma una palabra 5 quinto
y la unimos con millennial
están listos
se crea este concepto que por primera
vez de la luz al mundo
si penal
y les pongo un ejemplo los baby boomers
nuestros abuelos la generación de x
nuestros padres los millenials muchos de
nosotros generación z ustedes los
estudiantes universitarios y qué va a
pasar después
la respuesta chicos chicas se abocan los
tutoriales
quiero terminar esta charla con esta
fotografía
cuando yo tenía cinco años
soñaba y me preguntaba cuál es el
propósito cuál es mi meta de estar el
día de hoy aquí tenía una segunda
oportunidad y esta segunda oportunidad
es darle la respuesta de que es la
quinta revolución industrial de qué se
trata
en que tienen que especializarse en que
les recomiendo estudiar y sobre todo
trabajar y elaborarlo
este hashtag
poco a poco se va a viralizar
recuerden
si nosotros el día de hoy en puebla no
tomamos acción
la pregunta es dónde
si no es ahora cuándo
y si no somos cada uno de nosotros que
estamos en el escenario en el auditorio
y el día de hoy en este momento aquí
donde chicos la respuesta les quiero
decir que va a venir en 2030
y no va a ser ni inglaterra ni europa ni
suiza de alemania
la respuesta de dónde van a ser y dónde
son los albores de la quinta revolución
industrial es en puebla y por qué digo
este argumento
pueda tomar el año de la fundación de
nuestra ciudad
que muchos saben para 2030 cuántos años
va a estar cumpliendo puebla
vamos a estar en los albores de los 500
años de la fundación de puebla creen que
eso sea casualidad o hay una razón
especial en una razón mágica
yo creo que si no hay y ustedes son esos
tomadores de decisiones recuerden si
nosotros no tomamos de acción ahora la
pregunta es cuando si no lo hacemos aquí
en nuestra ciudad donde y si no somos
cada uno de nosotros entonces quién
muchísimas gracias
[Música]